they fail because most people are in the  Band-Aid business  they don't really want to fix their [ __ ]  they want to use this calendar flip as  like okay now I'm gonna get going but  it's it's it's it's surface level it's  not deep inside of you you're not really  really ready to make that relationship  change that job change that you know  mental health change that way of eating  and exercising change you don't really  mean it  you're just kind of looking for a quick  little Bolt  you know that same reason people are  into plastic surgery over over falling  in love with themselves or putting in  the work you know we just we're looking  for quick fixes everybody wants to [ __ ]  fast uh Jet fans want to fire their  coach after two years because they  didn't make the playoffs like people  like want promotion six months into  [ __ ] working somewhere even though  they haven't done [ __ ] we just want [ __ ]  too fast lack of patience [ __ ] you up  go deeper